[Music]
sky judge is dead
unless of course it isn't although what
the nfl has adopted is a far cry from
what the nfl needs to adopt this is a
play last year that would have been
subject and was subject to replay review
for past interference that ended up
being a debacle either because of the
concept or because of the execution that
is gone now that was the reaction of the
ram saints play so the new reaction of
the ram saints play from the 2018 nfc
championship game is to basically make
the replay assistant available to the
referee
if the referee initiates
the communication with the replay
assistant nobody buzzes down to the
referee the referee is the one that has
to acknowledge hey maybe there's a
reason to talk to the replay assistant
and see if we can get some help from the
replay assistant who's already there
anyway they already have that position
staffed there are six points that the
referee can seek input from the replay
assistant on gaming administration
complete incomplete or intercepted pass
touching of a loose ball boundary line
goal line or end line location of the
ball in relation to a boundary line the
line of scrimmage the line to gain or
the goal line down by contact if the
ruling on the field was not down by
contact and status of the game clock
regarding when the time on the game
clock can be restored those are the six
ways big cat that the referee can talk
to the replay assistant during the game
for input now they're doing this on an
experimental basis for the preseason
they may adopt it for the regular season
they want to see how this works
here's the problem
and
right the whole purpose of trying to fix
the system was to prevent another rams
saints non-call of pass interference in
a playoff game debacle
this
system
omits
the ability of the referee to get any
input from the replay assistance whether
or not there is an egregious instance of
passing interference so it doesn't fix
the original problem that's what's so
bizarre about it they have this major
problem that sparks a reaction last year
to try to fix it what they did last year
didn't work so now this year well we got
to do something else we got to look i
think it all comes out of this we have
to look like we give a crap we have to
look like we're trying to make things
better this will make it look like we're
trying
even though this procedure would never
if it was in place in 2018 would never
have fixed the ram saints non-call of
pass interference debacle it's
ridiculous that we've gotten to this
point where they're coming up with
solutions that don't address the problem
well it goes back to my original point
that there isn't a major problem that
was an overreaction after an egregious
play they obviously had huge
repercussions and cost the saints a spot
in the super bowl but
it happens
huge no huge repercussions because
screwed the saints out of an appearance
in the super bowl that they aren't why
it really isn't a big problem mike come
on again mike again though what happened
against the saints is egregious i don't
disagree with that it has been it has
happened once once
and now we're going to once this is too
many times
i understand what your your thought
process might be
just don't do anything
the nfl became unwatchable when it came
to the past interference reviews last
year it was a terrible implementation of
a rule that was trying to fix this
one-off situation that a ref completely
missed and i agree so it goes back to my
original point mike that forget all of
this stuff just give me the big button
give me the big button that someone can
mash if something like that ever happens
again and guess what but this isn't the
big problem again i know this isn't the
big button
i agree but it it yeah but i i think
reviewing past interference giving the
refs the ability to review past
interference is still the wrong way to
do it because they will use it too many
times it needs to
literally just be
if there is a
blatant egregious rule miss and that
really happened in that saints rams game
and it doesn't happen often if at all
like to that level where there's no
nuance it's cut and dry that was a past
interference it should have been a past
interference they completely missed it
i i really do think it i know what your
frustration is i understand that it you
know there's a lot of different things
at play here gambling is is a very good
point by you the fact that it happens
just once is too many times but i can't
tell you enough from the viewers
perspective
watching the game and watching past
interference replays and trying to
decipher whether a guy passed interfered
on a slow-motion replay
really hurts the viewership of the game
and really hurts watching the game the
game experience and having just even the
refs ability to do that doesn't fix the
problem because they will do it they
will check so many times just to make
sure if a guy's sitting there and yeah i
hear you hitting the button it's going
to be the same thing just a different
way
i hear you i hear you a couple of things
first of all
the whole thing about i wanted replay
review for pass interference i know it's
a funny shtick for you like admitting
you know you're sorry i never wanted i
never wanted replay review for passenger
friends and i don't want replay review
for past interference i want something
to fix what happened last year
in january in the ram saints nfc
championship game what what
frustrates me about this
is they are wasting time they are
wasting resources they're wasting effort
creating a system
that is aimed at making us think they've
addressed the problem when they aren't
addressing the problem they're
addressing a different problem they're
addressing a separate problem and
they're making the replay assistant
available to the referee if the referee
happens to realize oh you know what we
may have screwed that play up that's
what's ridiculous about it here's what
they're doing number one they don't want
to undermine in any way the referee and
this gets into politics and the referee
and the status of the referee and you
don't want to have someone in that booth
that is looking over the referee's
shoulder god forbid anyone should be
looking over the shoulder of someone who
is charged with administering the rules
correctly oh we can't have that so they
don't want someone who has power that is
equal to or greater than the referee to
buzz down and say hey you may want to
drop a flag there so they've they've set
this up to give the referee full power
secondly they don't want to pay big cat
that's what this comes down to they
don't want to hire 17 people to serve as
sky judge so they're going to have the
replay assistant who's already under
salary already under contract who is
there in the event the referee decides
hey you know what maybe i need to talk
to the replay assistant and and they
save the money and the time and the
effort for creating this separate system
so they've come up with something to
make it look like they're doing
something when in reality they're doing
nothing i have the fix mike i have the
fix i am i am fixing the nfl this
morning and i know you'll probably poke
holes at this but this one works
you're fixing it in the way a dog gets
fixed i think but go ahead no i'm gonna
tell you the fix you don't even know the
fix there's a challenge flat red
challenge flag that all coaches get when
they get to a game
give them an extra flag it's the black
flag
it challenges any play
any play no matter what you can
challenge you can challenge uh the the
rule when they when they say that uh a
defensive lineman puts too much weight
on a quarterback you can challenge past
interference you can challenge the spot
of the ball you can challenge out of
bounds you can challenge any single play
in a game with the black challenge flag
and you get one and you better use it or
or if you use it you lose it but but you
get one and that's it you get one and
that and you hold on to it no and you
get that and and mike the added bonus of
you get uh coaches trying to figure out
which flags which and they're trying to
pull out like they pull out the black
flag accidentally when they meant to
pull out the red flag and we get chaos
there that is unintentional hilarious
chaos that happens from my rule my rule
works
well first of all jeff fisher won't be
back in the league for that to happen
second of all here's the problem if you
let them challenge anything and they
challenge past interference then we're
back to where we were last year but
without river ron hang on hang on
without but still still one game the
standard is here the next game the
standard is here it's moving around all
year long and it's basically no you
don't you don't want replay to be the
equivalent of shaking a magic eight ball
which is what it became last year here's
what they need to do and i'm going to
agree with something you said several
minutes ago and let's go let's circle
back to that and we have to leave it
there
i believe there should be
the red button the break glass in event
of emergency i believe that al riveron
considered doing that by using the
pipeline the microphone that he has at
345 park avenue or if he's on site at a
big game where he can talk directly to
the referee i believe he considered in
the ram saints game saying drop a flag
even though the rules say you can't do
that that's that's not what that
pipeline is there for i think he
considered it and he decided i can't do
it and that was his mistake he should
have done it imagine if he would have
done it what we've been talking about
for the last 15 months i guess we should
be grateful he didn't do it so the point
is
and maybe maybe this system is cover
for
the big button
and if it's not al riveron that hits the
button somebody needs to be sitting next
to him who is higher on the pecking
order than he is and there aren't a
whole lot of people in the league office
higher on the pecking order i can think
of two troy vincent and roger goodell
but somebody needs to be saying to al
riveron if he's not going to hit the
button you hit the button and the bigger
the game the more important it is that
somebody else is telling him hit the
button this is an egregious play and if
we don't fix this we're going to have
six months of crap from fans from media
from congress from whoever especially is
gambling proliferation
boy it was great until i couldn't land
the plane no you could already baby i
agree
i agree with everything you said
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports